every pianist has desired to play with
themselves is also a way of spreading
information because people couldn't get
to Orchestra yes it always lists
promoting these composers just wanted to
do something else he wanted to actually
in a perfect way take a whole Orchestra
and put it into the piano or we'd said I
regret that I have never played the
Beethoven symphonies in the list
arrangement for these are the hardest
things ever written and there's not one
notes that they told them did that he
did not get onto the piano somehow so
you see as Thomas Mann said the piano is
the intellectualization of all music on
one compass it's incredible how's your
finger okay
let's do let's do let's do the amazing
transcription from the Rigoletto quartet
from Veronese Opera Rigoletto and he
takes it and he makes it into a piano
work he mystifies the very simplistic
harmonic stuff of Verdi and this even
here in the opiez an opening is like the
overture with the stage openings and
here you see the lights it's an amazing
work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
yeah
ah
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
you
[Applause]